last week this is crazy India's highest
court ruled it adultery will no longer
be considered a criminal offense it was
a criminal offense yeah before this a
person could go to jail in India for up
to five years for committing adultery
but not anymore you can no longer go to
jail there isn't that crazy Andy Andy
[Music]
and II the law only applies to Indian
citizens yeah they told me about that
I'm sorry okay
Indian citizens saying do you mind if I
move on sure sure go go ahead moving on
Las Vegas has opened a cannabis museum
that features this is true a 24 foot
bong called bongs illa yes
now this seemed to me like kind of a
lame publicity stunt don't you think
Andy oh come on Andy
and II the bong is just for decoration
it's not a functioning bong it it turns
out the bong is just for decoration it's
not a functioning bomb yeah I know let's
get through the monologue okay
sure okay hey interesting medical story
check this out in Denmark researchers
have discovered that injecting millions
of stem cells into the base of the penis
could not only cure erectile dysfunction
but even enlarge the penis isn't that
insane I think that's crazy yeah
that's madness what do you think Andy
well it sounds promising but I mean what
guy would want to jab a needle into the
base of their penis on the off chance
that'll help them get hard
[Applause]
Coenen read the article they've only
tried it on tiny rat penises
[Applause]
your insurance won't cover it you'll
have to pay out of pocket
[Music]
that's right ladies and gentlemen you
heard me right I have a rat sized penis
and I'm tight with a dollar
you
you